si el razonador disfruta del conflicto y la lucha.
¿Puede la razón forzar al razonador para querer
menos crueldad y pérdidas?
RNG: Por sí sola, la respuesta es no.
Sin embargo, no se requiere mucho para cambiarla a "sí".
Necesitas dos condiciones:
La primera es que todos los razonadores se preocupen
por su propio bienestar.
Esa es una de las pasiones que necesita estar presente
para que la razón se ponga a trabajar,
y obviamente se encuentra presente en cada uno de nosotros.
Todos nos preocupamos apasionadamente
por nuestro bienestar.
La segunda condición es que los razonadores
sean miembros de una comunidad
que pueda afectar el bienestar del otro,
que pueda intercambiar mensajes
y comprender el razonamiento del otro.
Y eso es ciertamente el caso de nuestra gregaria
y locuaz especie,
bien dotada con el instinto para el lenguaje.
SP: Bueno, eso suena bien en teoría,
pero ¿ha funcionado así en la práctica?
En particular, ¿puede explicar
un acontecimiento histórico trascendental
del que hablé hace cinco años aquí en TED?
Es decir, parecemos ser cada vez más humanos.
Hace siglos, nuestros antepasados quemaban gatos vivos
como forma de entretenimiento popular.
Los caballeros guerreaban constantemente
intentando matar a tantos campesinos como fuese posible.
Los gobiernos ejecutaban a la gente por razones tan frívolas
como robar una col
o criticar el jardín real.
Las ejecuciones se diseñaban para ser tan prolongadas
y dolorosas como fuese posible, como la crucifixión,
el destripamiento o la rueda.
Personas respetables tenían esclavos.
A pesar de nuestros defectos, hemos abandonado
estas prácticas bárbaras.
RNG: ¿Crees que es la naturaleza humana lo que ha cambiado?
SP: No exactamente. Creo que aún albergamos instintos
que pueden estallar en violencia,
como la codicia, el tribalismo, la venganza, el dominio o el sadismo.
Pero también tenemos instintos que pueden alejarnos,
como el autocontrol, la empatía, el sentido de la justicia,
lo que Abraham Lincoln llamaba
"los mejores ángeles de nuestra naturaleza".
RNG: Entonces, si la naturaleza humana no cambió,
¿qué vigorizó a esos "mejores ángeles"?
SP: Bueno, entre otras cosas,
nuestro círculo de empatía se expandió.
Años atrás, nuestros antepasados sentían
únicamente el dolor de su familia y de la gente de su pueblo.
Pero con la expansión de la alfabetización y los viajes,
la gente comenzó a simpatizar
con círculos cada vez más amplios:
el clan, la tribu, la nación, la raza,
y tal vez eventualmente, toda la humanidad
RNG: ¿Pueden realmente los científicos cerrados
dar tanto crédito a una empatía blanda?
SP: Pueden y lo hacen.
Los neurofisiólogos han encontrado neuronas en el cerebro
que responden a las acciones de otras personas
de la misma manera en que responden a las propias.
La empatía surge temprano en la vida,
quizás antes del primer año de edad.
Los libros sobre empatía se han convertido en los más vendidos,
como "La Civilización Empática"
y "La Edad de la Empatía".
RNG: Estoy a favor de la empatía, ¿quién no lo está?
Pero por sí sola es un instrumento débil
para el progreso moral.
Por un lado, se inclina de manera innata
hacia las relaciones consanguíneas, los bebés
y los animales peludos y cariñosos.
Por lo que a la empatía se refiere,
los raros feos pueden irse al demonio.
E incluso nuestros mejores intentos para desarrollar simpatía
por aquellos que no están conectados con nosotros
se quedan miserablemente cortos; una triste verdad sobre la naturaleza humana
que fue señalada por Adam Smith
Adam Smith: Supongamos que al gran imperio
de China se lo tragara repentinamente un terremoto,
y consideremos cómo reaccionaría un hombre en Europa
al enterarse
de esta terrible calamidad.
Él, imagino, antes que todo expresaría con mucha fuerza
su dolor por la desgracia de aquella pobre gente.
Haría muchas reflexiones melancólicas
sobre la precariedad de la vida humana,
y para cuando todos estos sentimientos humanos
hayan sido lo suficientemente expresados,
continuaría con sus actividades o placeres
con la misma facilidad y tranquilidad
como si no hubiese existido tal catástrofe.
Si él fuese a perder su dedo meñique el día de mañana,
seguramente no dormiría en toda la noche;
pero como nunca conoció a toda esa gente,
roncaría con la más profunda tranquilidad,
encima de la ruina de millones de personas.
SP: Pero si la empatía no fue suficiente para hacernos más humanos
¿qué más había ahí?
RNG: Bien, jamás mencionaste lo que podría ser
uno de nuestros más efectivos "mejores ángeles": la razón.
La razón tiene fuerza.
Es la razón la que proporciona el impulso para ampliar
ese círculo de empatía.
Cada uno de los desarrollos humanitarios
que mencionaste se originaron con los pensadores
quienes dieron las razones por las cuáles algunas prácticas
eran indefendibles.
Ellos demostraron que la forma en que las personas trataban
a ciertos grupos de individuos
era lógicamente inconsistente
con la forma en la que insistían ser tratados ellos mismos.
SP: ¿Estás insinuando que la razón
puede realmente cambiar la mentalidad de las personas?
¿Acaso la gente no simplemente se aferra a cualquier creencia
que sirva a sus intereses
o que forme parte de la cultura en la que crecieron?
RNG: Aquí hay un hecho fascinante sobre nosotros:
Las contradicciones nos molestan,
al menos cuando somos forzados a enfrentarlas,
lo cual es simplemente otra manera de decir
que somos susceptibles a la razón.
Y si observas la historia del progreso moral,
se puede trazar una ruta directa desde argumentos razonados
hasta los cambios en la manera en que realmente sentimos.
Una y otra vez, un pensador diseñaría un argumento
del por qué alguna práctica era indefensible,
irracional, inconsistente con los valores ya arraigados.
Su ensayo se volvería viral,
se traduciría a varios idiomas,
se debatiría en bares, cafeterías, salones de belleza,
y en cenas;
e influenciaría a líderes, legisladores
y a la opinión popular.
Finalmente sus conclusiones serían absorbidas
por el sentido común de la decencia,
borrando las huellas del argumento original
que nos había traído hasta allí.
Hoy en día pocos de nosotros sienten alguna necesidad por exponer
un argumento filosófico riguroso
del por qué la esclavitud es mala
o los ahorcamientos públicos o golpear a los niños.
A estas alturas, estas cosas simplemente no se sienten bien.
Sin embargo, esos argumentos tuvieron que haberse hecho,
y se hicieron, siglos atrás.
SP: ¿Estás diciendo que la gente necesitaba
un argumento paso a paso para entender
por qué algo podía estar un poquito mal
al quemar herejes en la hoguera?
RNG: Oh, lo necesitaron. Aquí tenemos al teólogo francés
Sebastian Catellio planteando el caso.
Sebastian Castellio: Calvino dice que tiene la razón
y otras sectas dicen que ellas la tienen.
¿A quién deberíamos juzgar?
Si el asunto es cierto, ¿a quién juzgar? ¿A Calvino?
Pero entonces, ¿por qué escribe tantos libros sobre manifestar la verdad?
En vista de la incertidumbre, debemos definir a los herejes
simplemente como alguien con quien no estamos de acuerdo.
Y si entonces vamos a matar herejes,
el resultado lógico será una guerra de exterminación,
puesto que cada quién está seguro de sí mismo.
SP: ¿O con castigos terribles
como la rueda?
RNG: La prohibición en nuestra Constitución
de castigos crueles e inusuales
fue una respuesta a un panfleto que circulaba en 1764
por el jurista italiano Cesare Beccaria.
Cesare Beccaria: Mientras los castigos se vuelven más crueles,
las mentes de los hombres, que como fluidos
siempre se ajustan al nivel de los objetos
que los rodean, se endurecen,
y después de cien años de castigos crueles,
la rueda no causa más miedo
que el encarcelamiento previamente realizado.
Para que un castigo alcance su objetivo,
solo es necesario que el daño que inflige
supere el beneficio del crimen,
y dentro de este cálculo debe tenerse en cuenta
la certeza del castigo
y la pérdida del bien
que la comisión del delito producirá.
todo más allá de esto es superfluo,
y por tanto, tiránico.
SP: Pero ciertamente los movimientos contra la guerra dependieron
de la manifestación masiva,
de melodías pegajosas de cantantes populares
y de fotografías desgarradoras de los costos humanos de la guerra.
RNG: No hay duda, sin embargo, los movimientos contra la guerra
se remontan a una larga cadena de pensadores
que habían discutido el porqué debíamos movilizar
nuestras emociones en contra de la guerra,
tal como el padre de la modernidad, Erasmo.
Erasmo: Las ventajas derivadas de la paz
se difunden a sí mismas a lo largo y ancho,
y alcanzan grandes números,
mientras que en la guerra, si algo resulta bien,
la ventaja redunda solo en unos cuantos,
aquellos indignos de cosecharla.
La seguridad de un hombre se debe a la destrucción de otro.
El premio de un hombre resulta del saqueo de otro.
La causa de regocijo de un lado,
es motivo de luto del otro.
Lo que sea lamentable en la guerra,
es tan grave de hecho,
y lo que, en el lado contrario
es llamada buena fortuna,
se trata de una buena fortuna salvaje y cruel,
una felicidad poco generosa que debe su existencia a la aflicción de otros.
SP: Pero todo el mundo sabe que el movimiento
para abolir la esclavitud dependió de la fe y la emoción.
Fue un movimiento encabezado por los cuáqueros,
y que solamente llegó a ser popular cuando la novela de Harriet Beecher Stowe
"La Cabaña del Tío Tom" se convirtió en éxito de ventas.
RNG: Pero este proceso se puso en marcha un siglo atrás.
John Locke detuvo los milenios
en los que esta práctica era vista como algo perfectamente natural
Argumentó que era incongruente
con los principios del gobierno racional.
John Locke: La libertad de los hombres bajo el gobierno
es tener una regla permanente para vivir
como iguales en esa sociedad
y hacer, por medio del poder legislativo erigido en ella,
una libertad para seguir la voluntad propia en todas las cosas
donde dicha regla prescribe
no ser sujeto de la inconstante,
incierta, desconocida y arbitraria voluntad de otro hombre,
ya que la libertad de la naturaleza consiste en no estar bajo ninguna restricción
salvo la ley de la naturaleza.
SP: Esas palabras me suenan familiares.
¿Dónde las he leído antes? Oh, sí.
Mary Astell: Si la soberanía absoluta no fuese necesaria
en un estado, ¿cómo podría serlo en una familia?
O si lo es en una familia, ¿por qué no en un estado?
Puesto que ninguna razón puede ser alegada para uno
que no sea firmemente llevada a cabo para el otro,
si todos los hombres nacen libres,
¿cómo puede ser que todas las mujeres nazcan siendo esclavas,
como deben serlo si son sometidas
a la inconstante, incierta,
desconocida y arbitraria voluntad de los hombres;
la condición perfecta de la esclavitud?
RNG: Ese tipo de cooptación
se incluye completamente en la descripción del trabajo de la razón.
Un movimiento a favor de la expansión de los derechos
inspira a otro porque la lógica es la misma,
y una vez que se ha alcanzado,
se vuelve cada vez más incómodo
ignorar la inconsistencia.
En los años sesenta, el Movimiento por los Derechos Civiles
inspiró los movimientos a favor de los derechos de la mujer,
los derechos de los niños, los derechos de los homosexuales e incluso los derechos de los animales.
Sin embargo, dos siglos atrás,
el pensador de la Ilustración Jeremy Bentham
había expuesto la total indefensión
de prácticas habituales tal como
el maltrato a los animales.
Jeremy Bentham: La pregunta no es si razonan,
tampoco si pueden hablar, la pregunta es ¿pueden sufrir?
RNG: Y la persecución de los homosexuales.
JB: En cuanto a cualquier daño principal,
es evidente que no produce dolor a nadie.
Por el lado contrario, produce placer.
Los socios están ambos dispuestos.
Si alguno de ellos no lo estuviera,
el acto sería una ofensa,
totalmente diferente en su naturaleza de efectos.
Es una lesión personal. Es una especie de violación.
En cuanto al peligro exclusivo del dolor,
el peligro, si lo hay, consiste básicamente
en la tendencia del ejemplo.
Pero ¿qué es la tendencia de este ejemplo?
Disponer a otros para participar en las mismas prácticas.
Pero esta practica no produce dolor de ningún tipo
a nadie.
SP: Aún así, en cada caso, tomó cuando menos un siglo
para que los argumentos de estos grandes pensadores
se asentaran e infiltraran a la población como un todo.
Esto como que te hace preguntarte acerca de nuestro tiempo.
¿Existen prácticas en las que nos involucramos
dónde los argumentos en contra de estas se encuentran ahí para que todos los veamos
y sin embargo, persistimos en ellos?
RNG: Cuando nuestros bisnietos se vuelvan a observarnos,
¿estarán tan consternados por algunas de nuestras prácticas
como lo estamos nosotros con respecto a la posesión de esclavos, la quema de herejes,
el maltrato a la mujer y a los homosexuales de nuestros ancestros?
SP: Estoy seguro de que todo el mundo podría pensar en un ejemplo.
RNG: Opto por el maltrato a los animales
en las granjas industriales.
SP: El encarcelamiento de delincuentes de drogas no violentos
y la tolerancia de la violación en las prisiones de nuestra nación.
RNG: El escatimar en las donaciones a las organizaciones benéficas que salvan vidas
en los países en desarrollo.
SP: La posesión de armas nucleares.
RNG: El argumento de la religión para justificar
lo que de otra manera sería injustificable,,
como la prohibición de loa anticonceptivos.
SP: ¿Qué sucede con la fe religiosa en general?
RNG: Eh, no metería las manos al fuego.
SP: Aún así, me he convencido
de que la razón es un mejor ángel
que merece el mayor crédito
por el progreso moral que nuestra especie ha disfrutado
y que encierra la mayor esperanza
para continuar con el progreso moral en el futuro.
RNG: Y amigos, si
detectan alguna falla en este argumento,
simplemente recuerden que dependerán de la razón
para señalarla.
Gracias. SP: Gracias
(Aplausos)